today me and my boys we're going to go
out survival camping using primitive
fishing techniques but before we get
started i want to take a moment to thank
this video's sponsor grizzwiss
invented by survival expert and tv
personality bear grylls grizzwiz is the
ultimate survival drink and it just
might save your life grizz whiz is 100
organic all natural gluten free and it's
made from bear grylls own dehydrated
urine that's dehydrated pee that's right
bear grizz will tell anyone that in any
survival situation the first thing you
do is drink your own urine
however for most of us the thought of
drinking our own urine is a bit daunting
but luckily we have grizwiz so we don't
have to drink our own urine we can drink
bear grylls urine
all you have to do is mix one scoop of
grizz whiz dehydrated urine powder with
any source of fresh clean water and
there you have it instant fresh urine
after all you pee more than water so why
shouldn't you drink more than water but
grizz whiz isn't just a survival tool
it's also great for rehydrating after
workouts and for passing random drug
tests and now grizzwiz comes in two
flavors original flavor and asparagus
also don't forget to check out bear
grylls new line of survival bars for a
smooth healthy snack out on the trail
don't forget to use promo code outdoor
boys to get this awesome griz whiz
survival flask with your first purchase
of any of the new griz whiz products
and once again thank you grizzwiz for
sponsoring this video
enjoy the show
[Music]
guys guys we've gotta go we gotta run
mom knows what you did to her dress
nathan
and mom found your pants under the bed
yes the ones with the fish
go into there my pencils
three days later
tommy
why are you scared
happy birthday
i told you i wouldn't forget
it's the new taiwan gas vr speeding reel
run
we need to get out of here we need to
get out of town let's go
oh man you guys are in so much trouble
we have got to get out of town mom can
track the car we've got to get rid of
the car
[Music]
look at this as soon as i catch one
decent fish these guys set up their rigs
right next to me and cast over my lines
now this is easily a situation that
could escalate to something ugly but i'm
going to show you the right way to
handle this okay
[Applause]
this is my spot don't cast over my lines
oh
[Music]
hey wait a minute are you mark luke yeah
hey
oh man yeah we totally fished together
was awesome yeah you want to come i got
my boys here we got oh yeah it's michael
him and mike right well haley you guys
want to fish with us dude come here come
upstairs get right over here man i'm
good to see you
boys time to clean up look at this mess
boys boys
time to clean up
mom
what did you say to your mother
uh
no i got you now
oh i'm gonna teach you a lesson
so i will ask you one more time where do
you catch your fish
i'll tell you where i catch my fish in
the water
so
you are tougher than i anticipated
i commend you mr nichols
but perhaps
physical persuasion
is not what you need
do you know where your wife is right now
mr nicholas
you monster what have you done with
becca
no no i haven't done anything to her
yet
see for yourself
bring her in
hi honey how's your video going do you
think you're gonna be done by seven
we have some friends coming over for
dinner tonight yeah baby that shouldn't
be a problem we'll be done by seven
right no no that shouldn't be a problem
no we'll seven's good yeah babe i'll
make sure to get home in time to clean
up before they arrive love you
so help me dr evil if you harm one hair
on her head you'll live to regret it
no no no i will not have the young lady
but if you did not tell us how to locate
more fish
i will tell her
how much you spend on fitting gear
oh that's just silly luke hasn't bought
any fishing gear lately
okay i'll tell you anything you want to
know
start digging right there
stick it right there think right there
oh you see it yeah oh hey it's pretty
big yeah what is that
looks like some sort of note
[Music]
are you good nathan
okay good night bud
poor becca's probably at home worried
sick of us crying herself to sleep i
feel bad about that i really do
[Music]
i'm going to show you how you can find
food using only basic tools that you
might find in your pockets no specialty
snares or bows and arrows or anything
this is really basic hunter gathering uh
yeah i'd like to order for delivery
oh it also i ain't gonna coupon for a
free sweet sour chicken i'm sorry i
should have mentioned that earlier i've
got a stinky jacob here
oh yeah he's ripe time to load the butt
zuka
ready
aim
[Music]
luke tom and nate here with the outdoor
boys youtube channel and i'm going to
show you how to track
toddlers
[Music]
christmas
[Music]
luke here with the outdoor boys youtube
channel and today we're reviewing the
cheapest and most expensive baby on
amazon.com
okay tommy go to the bathroom just do
not touch anything okay
few moments later
i told you not to touch anything
well guys it is a lovely full moon
halloween night shall we go for a little
hike yeah all right let's go let's go
for a hike in the woods
oh it's getting a little foggy tonight
hey guys should we go and wander deeper
into the woods without a trail
stay close we don't want you to
disappear like all those other kids that
disappeared this week
hey guys i heard a strange noise should
we go and investigate yeah yeah
oh this fog is getting thick
beckham have you seen tommy no
tommy
tommy ah let's go deeper into the woods
to look for tommy
[Music]
do you know where nathan is no
nathan yeah nathan's gone too darn it
all right let's go deeper into the woods
and see if we can't find him okay
okay
oh this fog is thick
i don't see nathan or tommy anywhere do
you
hey becca
didn't you have jacob
oh crap we lost jacob too
[Music]
becca we've lost tommy nathan and jacob
do you know what this means
[Music]
hey baby
you like my squirrel blade
nope
yeah yeah
all natural
like me now kodiak island is a little
bit south of anchorage
it's a big island full of deer
and salmon
and killer grizzly bears
these bears get over 11 feet tall you
know kodiak grizzly bears are so fast
they can outrun
deer and they like to attack hunters
when they hear a gun go off
they know that someone shot a deer so
they run over and attack the hunter and
take his deer many hunters have been
killed by grizzly bears
hey becca can i have another boat
you already have tons of boats no i
don't
what's that this is just a pontoon boat
and what's that this this is just a
skiff and what's that i don't think
kayaks should count does this one count
no i only use this for shark fishing and
and this one this is a stand up paddle
board not a stand-up paddle boat and
what about the paddle boat
it was on sale
luke you can't buy any more boats i
won't
buy
any more boats
loophole
loopholes
[Music]
are you luke
you chris
how do i know you're not a cop would a
cop do this
all right you're not a cop but how do i
know you're not wearing a wire
all right
if you want to go to my secret fishing
spot
you're gonna have to wear this
all right
nice fishing
yes sir let's go check it out
look at nate here and today we are doing
something super crazy we are making the
stinkiest the raunchiest catfish bait
ever and i'm using my wife's blender now
luckily she's not home today otherwise
she would murder us for this but we've
got some fermented shad guts and chicken
livers and
wait
do you hear that yeah
yeah mom's home we're dead we gotta get
out of here
[Music]
all right gotta get out of here
[Music]
hey guys i'm home
what's that smell
ugh
luke nathan where are you guys
ah
so
tommy we've got to get nathan we've got
to get mommy we gotta get out of here
let's go
let's go get mommy and nathan come on
right up the stairs buddy
okay
let's see i'm gonna go get nathan
come on nathan nathan nathan what's the
matter nathan
[Music]
oh no he's a zombie oh
my boy
we gotta go get mommy let's go get mommy
okay let's go mommy oh there she is
becca becca you're over there
get out of here
oh we gotta get out of here tommy
come on let's go
come on
let's go outside we need weapons and you
can't forget your house
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
all done
who left this here
yeah where did this come from
who's leaving dishes
boys jacob we're pinned down they've got
too good of guns come here
we need to do something drastic
this is the first time i've been healthy
in like three months you always get me
sick you gave me stomach flu you gave me
the cold you gave me strep throat
wait are you coughing on your darts
you're monsters
[Music]
i can't help but feel like we're
forgetting something
they aren't coming back are they
nope
i want to do a special thanks for this
video sponsor
the bright grabber 2000. as you guys
know children often carry diseases and
the brat grabber allows you to restrain
and capture children without having to
actually make contact with them isn't
that right jacob the brat grabber is
also great for getting down and it was
hard to reach places oh come here
but the brag grabber doesn't just grab
children it's great for all sorts of
household chores
we're gonna find hunt
gut
cook and eat our own veg
[Music]
[Applause]
there you go there you go dan
congratulations look at that you dropped
a sick beat
uh-oh
oh i think the boys goldfish is dead
they're gonna take this
[Music]
hard luke and tom here with the outdoor
boys youtube channel and today we're
going to make a survival shelter
out of duct tape yeah
wait wait wait for me
come on keep going
keep going we only have 15 more miles to
go you're tired
do you know who else was tired
the donner party they were tired guys
you hear that yes you hear that it's a
pack of wolves come on we gotta hurry up
come on find the wolves
if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor boys youtube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every saturday morning and hit
that bell button you'll get
notifications thanks for watching